So Miki, this is your high school.
那么Miki，这就是你的高中。
This is my high school. And it's really weird to be here with you, even though I suggested this. Even though this was my idea.
这是我的高中。能和你一起出现在这里真的很奇怪，尽管这是我提议的，尽管这原本是我的主意。
We're in Payson, Utah, a small town about an hour south of Salt Lake City. It's me and Miki Meek, one of the producers here at This American Life. She hasn't been back to her high school since she graduated, but says it looks the same. And same groups of kids too-- jocks, stoners, cowboys, regular kids.
我们在犹他州的佩森，这是盐湖城以南约一小时路程的一个小镇。和我在一起的是Miki Meek，她是《美国生活》的制作人之一。她自毕业以来就再没回过这所高中，但她说这里看起来一点没变。孩子们也还是那几类——运动员、吸大麻的、牛仔，还有普通学生。
And which were you?
那你属于哪一类？
I think I was a regular kid. Regular kid/county kid.
我想我当时是个普通学生。普通学生，也就是农村孩子。
OK, so you guys lived in the country.
好吧，所以你们当时住在乡下。
We lived in the country, yeah, yeah. Let's see, where are we are walking by now? Just walking through the hallway. This is the main hallway. Opening scenes of Footloose are right here.
我们住在乡下，没错。让我们看看，我们现在走过的是哪里？只是走廊而已。这是主走廊。《浑身是劲》（Footloose）的开场镜头就在这里拍的。
Oh, right. Payson High School is where they filmed Footloose.
噢，对了。佩森高中就是《浑身是劲》的取景地。
Yeah, the opening scene, so Kevin Bacon's first day of school. He walks past the cafeteria in this hallway, and a cowboy confronts him, right in this spot.
是的，开场那幕，凯文·贝肯第一天上学。他走过走廊里的自助餐厅，一个牛仔就在这个位置拦住了他。
Right in the spot where we're standing?
就在我们站的这个地方？
Right in the spot where we're standing, yeah.
没错，就在我们站的这个地方。
I downloaded the film later. Totally true. But of course, America, everybody knows there's a time to be born and a time die, and a time to dance, and a time to talk about Footloose. And this is not that time.
我后来下载了这部电影，完全属实。当然，美国人都知道，生有时，死有时，跳舞有时，谈论《浑身是劲》也有时。但现在不是时候。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
We are not here in Miki's school to talk about a movie about dancing. We're here to talk about real life dances at this high school, and more specifically, the way that the real life students ask each other to dances.
我们来Miki的学校并不是为了讨论一部关于跳舞的电影。我们是为了讨论这所高中里现实生活中的舞会，更具体地说，是这里的学生邀请彼此参加舞会的方式。
You ask someone to a dance, you've got to go big. Which means you've got to leave something on someone's porch. You gotta decorate their car. You gotta break into their bedroom. You gotta send them on a scavenger hunt.
你要邀请人去舞会，必须得搞大动作。这意味着你得在别人的门廊上留下点什么，你得装饰他们的车，你得潜入他们的卧室，或者让他们去进行一场寻宝游戏。
Break into their bedroom and do what?
潜入卧室做什么？
Decorate it, trash it, leave a message.
装饰它、搞乱它，或者留下一个信息。
The very minimum anybody does is a bit of prop humor. You leave some object and then a pun written on poster board. Like Owen Grimshaw was just asked to the Sadie Hawkins Dance this way.
最起码也得用道具耍点幽默。留下某个物品，再用海报板写上一句双关语。比如Owen Grimshaw最近就是这样被邀请去参加赛迪·霍金斯舞会的。
They had pants in a box. And they said "I'd ship my pants if you went to Sadie's with me."
他们在一个盒子里装了条裤子，写道：“如果你愿意和我一起去赛迪舞会，我一定会‘乐开花’（ship my pants/shit my pants谐音梗）。”
A senior, Ivan Webber, Told me about last year's Sweethearts dance, he took a laminated name tag, wrote a message on it, and then froze it in a block of ice, which he was very proud of.
高年级的Ivan Webber跟我讲了他去年参加情人节舞会的事，他用了一个覆膜的名牌，在上面写了条信息，然后把它冻在冰块里，他对此感到非常自豪。
I was just like, "Going to Sweethearts would be cool." And it was like, "it's pretty chill." Like, chill. OK?
我当时就说：“去参加情人节舞会会很酷（cool）。”这就像是说，“这很酷（chill）。” 对吧？
No, I get it.
不，我明白你的意思。
Sometimes the props they use are living animals. And some of these kids have access to farms. Ivan's little sister Mariah left a pair of goats at a guy's house with a poster.
有时他们使用的道具是活体动物。有些孩子家里有农场。Ivan的妹妹Mariah在某个男生的家里留了两只山羊，还带了一张海报。
And it said, "I'm not kidding. I would love to goat to Sadie's with you."
上面写着：“我没在开玩笑（kidding）。我很想和你一起去赛迪舞会（goat/go谐音）。”
Slight variation on that, senior Alyssa Sutton left a guy a basket with four baby kittens and this message.
类似的变化，高年级的Alyssa Sutton给一个男生留下了一个装有四只小猫的篮子，还有这条信息。
"I'm not kitten when I say I want to go to Sadie's with a cool cat like you."
“想和你这样酷的猫咪（cool cat）一起去参加赛迪舞会，我可没在开玩笑（kitten/kidding谐音）。”
Senior Ashlynn Yul left a chicken for a guy who asked her to a dance, a live chicken and Starbursts. The message?
高年级的Ashlynn Yul给一个邀请她去舞会的男生留下了一只鸡，一只活鸡和一些星爆糖。信息是什么？
"I'm not going to chicken out on you. I've been bursting to say yes."
“我才不会临阵退缩（chicken out）呢。我一直渴望（bursting）说愿意。”
The guy actually returned the chicken. The goat got returned too. The kittens stayed. Junior Caitlin Mitchell left a tree for her boyfriend.
那个男生确实把鸡退了回来。山羊也被退回来了。小猫留下了。低年级的Caitlin Mitchell给她的男友留了一棵树。
And I asked him, "It would be tree-mendous if you'd go to Sweethearts with me." And he answered back with "Needle-less to say, I'd be burning up if I'd said no." And he lit the trees on fire in my front yard.
我问他：“如果你能和我一起去情人节舞会，那真是太棒了（tree-mendous）。”他回复说：“不用说（Needle-less），如果我拒绝的话，我会后悔得要命。”然后他把我前院的树点着了。
Wait. He set them on fire?
等等。他把它们点着了？
Yeah. There was snow in my yard, so-- I mean--
是的。我的院子里有雪，所以——我的意思是——
Saying yes, you're supposed to be as creative as the person who asked you. Tyler Johnson told me about the time that his sister had a neighbor help her out with that. The neighbor was a policeman, and she hid in the back of his police car as he spotted the guy who asked her to dance.
答应邀请时，你也得像邀请你的人一样有创意。Tyler Johnson告诉我他姐姐有一次请邻居帮忙。那个邻居是个警察，当他在路上发现那个邀请她去舞会的男生时，她就藏在警车后座。
So I pulled him over. And at the time, the kid had a few-- I don't know, the point system, where you can get your license suspended. He was really close to getting his license suspended, so I thought it'd be extra funny. And so he pulled him over. Officer told him all these things that he did wrong. And he was freaking out. And then the officer gave him a ticket, and the ticket just said "yes," and then my sister's name on it.
所以我把他拦了下来。当时那个孩子因为扣分系统，驾照快要被吊销了，所以我认为这样会格外有趣。于是我拦下了他。警察告诉他所有违规的地方。他吓坏了。然后警察给了他一张罚单，罚单上只写着“愿意”，还有我姐姐的名字。
Incredibly, the guy still took her to the dance. It can be a ton of work doing these things. The most elaborate one I heard about was I met this one couple, Tyler Batty and Liz Callahan. And Tyler kidnapped Liz, this elaborate kidnapping-- duct tape, blanket over her head. She knew it was fake, by the way. Was not scared.
不可思议的是，那个男生还是带她去了舞会。做这些事可能需要耗费大量精力。我听说过最精心策划的一次，是关于一对情侣，Tyler Batty和Liz Callahan。Tyler绑架了Liz，精心设计的绑架——用胶带，头上套着毯子。顺便说一下，她知道这是假的。一点也不害怕。
There was three boys, and they were talking. They were trying to sound like they're terrorists kind of. They were trying to talk him in some weird language.
当时有三个男孩在说话，他们试图听起来像恐怖分子。他们试图用某种奇怪的语言跟他说话。
And we'd just kind of shout gibberish, just a mix of any foreign words we know from Japanese, Russian, Korean, kind of sticking to mostly like a Russian accent. Like this, deeper.
我们只是胡言乱语，混合了我们知道的任何外语，日语、俄语、韩语，大部分时间保持着俄语口音。就像这样，声音更深沉。
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
[胡言乱语]
Just kind of random stuff like that.
就是类似那种随意的声音。
Give me a little more.
再来一点。
It's not logical. Just shout random words.
这没有逻辑。只是大喊随机的词。
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
[胡言乱语]
Just random syllables and funny stuff, goofy stuff, yeah. But I mean, if you were wrapped up in a blanket and someone's talking like that, you're more than likely to be scared.
只是随机的音节和有趣、搞怪的东西。但我的意思是，如果你被毯子裹住，有人这样说话，你更有可能会被吓到。
I was like, I know it's you guys. And they were like, no you don't! What?
我当时就说，我知道是你们。他们就说，不，你不知道！什么？
There's no way she could have known who it was.
她不可能知道是谁。
So I was calling all their names out. I was like, I know you guys are right there.
所以我喊出了他们所有人的名字。我说，我知道你们就在那里。
They threw her into the back of an SUV and then swerved around the roads, up into the mountains. And then Tyler staged a rescue in a Batman costume, supposedly saving her from the fake kidnappers.
他们把她扔进SUV后座，然后在路上狂飙，一直开进山里。接着Tyler穿着蝙蝠侠服装上演了一场营救，假装把她从假绑架者手中救出来。
I just start flinging open doors, kind of punching my buddies kind of hard, so it sounds realistic. Of course, it's not super hard punches, but just they're grunting, and uh, oh. They're yelling stuff. "Get him. Where is he?" So I throw open the back hatch.
我只是开始猛地打开车门，用力揍我的伙伴们，这样听起来真实。当然，不是真用力打，但他们会嘟囔，噢。他们会喊。“抓住他。他在哪儿？”所以我猛地打开后车门。
He had his Batman mask on, and he has this Batman voice that he likes to talk in. And you can't really understand him.
他戴着蝙蝠侠面具，用他喜欢的那种蝙蝠侠声音说话。你根本听不懂他在说什么。
And I said-- man, what did I say? "Don't move. I'm here to rescue you."
我说——天哪，我说了什么？“别动。我来救你了。”
We came to Payson High School because our show this week is all about grand gestures. And while you hear about schools where kids do these kinds of things for prom-- in fact, right now MTV is casting a TV show called Promposal-- here in Utah and a few other places around the country, they make the grand move every dance-- homecoming, Sweethearts dance, Sadie Hawkins, Winter Ball. And when I was going around meeting kids and I'd break the news to them that kids elsewhere do not do this, they were surprised.
我们来到佩森高中是因为我们这周的节目是关于盛大姿态。虽然你听说过有些学校的孩子们在舞会季做这些事——事实上，MTV目前正在拍摄一部名为《舞会邀请》的电视节目——但在犹他州和全国其他几个地方，他们每次舞会都会搞这种盛大的举动——返校节、情人节舞会、赛迪·霍金斯舞会、冬季舞会。当我见到孩子们，告诉他们其他地方的学生不会这样做时，他们都很惊讶。
Really?
真的吗？
This is a junior everybody calls Juddy Bear.
这是低年级的学生，大家都叫他Juddy Bear。
No other states?
其他州都没有？
Most places don't.
大多数地方都没有。
Wow. Well, that would be terrifying, because then she could say no to my face, rather than say no through a creative way.
哇。那太可怕了，因为她可能会当面拒绝我，而不是通过这种创意的方式拒绝。
Alyssa Sutton knew the truth about how kids elsewhere ask each other to dances, but she had a special source that gave her insight into how people live outside of Utah.
Alyssa Sutton知道其他地方的孩子是如何邀请舞伴的真相，但她有一个特殊的渠道了解犹他州以外的人们是如何生活的。
I found that out from reading Harry Potter. When they just asked each other to the Yule Ball, I was like what the heck? Do people actually do that? And I was like, I thought it would just be so awkward, though, to walk up and be like, "Hey, so you want to go to the dance?" And then you wouldn't know. You don't have anything to post on social media and say like, "Oh, they asked me with kittens or on a scavenger hunt."
我是从读《哈利·波特》中发现的。当他们邀请舞伴去圣诞舞会时，我想，这到底是什么鬼？人们真的那样做吗？我觉得，走过去说：“嘿，你想和我一起去舞会吗？”那太尴尬了。而且你也没法在社交媒体上发布什么，说：“噢，他们用小猫或寻宝游戏邀请了我。”
The kids I talked to said this idea of just walking up to somebody out of the blue, and then just asking them to a dance, it seems lame. Like, where is the effort? If doing these elaborate schemes just sounds like so much work and so much fuss just to ask somebody to a dance, a bunch of kids told me, no, no, no. It's like this project. You draft your friends into it. The invitation is a whole activity itself.
我采访的孩子们说，这种突如其来走过去邀请别人参加舞会的想法看起来很烂。因为努力在哪里？如果这些精心设计的计划听起来只是为了邀请某人去舞会而付出的巨大努力和骚动，许多孩子告诉我，不，不，不。这就像一个项目。你招募朋友一起参与。邀请本身就是一项活动。
She lives just over here, and there's a little park right next to her house. And that's where we're gonna bury it. Hopefully, she doesn't see us as we drive by.
她就住在旁边，房子旁边有个小公园。那就是我们要埋藏东西的地方。希望我们开车经过时她没看见。
Case in point, one day after school, I joined Ivan Webber-- the kid who froze the laminated name tag and thought it was chill-- and his little sister Mariah, and his friends, Ezri, Max, and Kylie, to bury in the snow a little treasure chest-- actually an old wooden jewelry box Ivan got at a thrift store.
举个例子，一天放学后，我加入了Ivan Webber——就是那个把覆膜名牌冻起来觉得很酷的孩子——还有他的妹妹Mariah，以及他的朋友Ezri、Max和Kylie，一起在雪地里埋一个小宝箱——实际上是Ivan在旧货店买的一个旧木制首饰盒。
It has a note inside to the girl who asked Ivan to go to the Sweethearts dance, a note saying yes. We get to a little park about a block from his date's house. It's a bright, clear sky day. Ivan is like a skinny, teenaged Tom Hanks, wearing just a green t-shirt, even though it's freezing outside.
里面有一张给邀请Ivan参加情人节舞会的女孩的便条，便条上写着愿意。我们到达了离他约会对象家一个街区远的小公园。天空明亮晴朗。Ivan就像一个瘦削的少年版汤姆·汉克斯，尽管外面天寒地冻，他却只穿了一件绿色T恤。
OK, we may have spray paint and a shovel, but we're definitely not going to be using them in a murder vandalism type way. Yeah, so the spray paint is to make the X for where we're going to bury the treasure chest in the snow. And the shovel is for her to dig it up. And this is where we have our note. This is our note. We're going to put it on the shovel and leave it at her doorstep.
好吧，我们可能有喷漆和铲子，但我们绝对不是要用那种谋杀破坏的方式。喷漆是为了在雪地里埋宝箱的地方画一个X。铲子是让她挖出来的。这是我们的便条。这是我们的便条。我们要把它放在铲子上，留在她家门前。
It says "It would be neat if you went down the street. The X marks the spot. There may be treasure, or maybe not." That's pretty good in my opinion.
上面写着“如果你顺着这条街走，那就太棒了。X代表目的地。里面可能有宝藏，也可能没有。”在我看来，这很不错。
We tromp around a little bit. The snow's maybe a foot deep.
我们四处踩了踩。雪大约有一英尺深。
OK, where do we want to bury this? We do it by one of these trees? We'll do it by that tree. OK, what if we just do it right there? That looks good. What if we just do it right there?
好吧，我们想把这埋在哪儿？我们把它放在这些树旁？我们就放在那棵树旁边吧。好吧，如果我们直接放在那里呢？看起来不错。如果我们直接放在那里呢？
[SHOVELING]
[铲雪声]
They put the wooden box in the hole, cover it over again with snow, pat it down.
他们把木箱放进坑里，再次用雪覆盖，拍实。
Yeah, we're going to spray paint it now.
是的，我们要喷漆了。
[SHAKING SPRAY CAN]
[摇晃喷漆罐的声音]
OK, drawing an X.
好了，画个X。
What color is this?
这是什么颜色？
It's the leftover stuff we had in our garage color. That pinkish, fleshy, salmon color.
这是我们在车库剩下的颜色。那种粉红的、肉色的、三文鱼的颜色。
Ezri points out it's less pirate and more bladder infection. Our treasure marked and now buried in the snow, Ivan takes the shovel and the note and heads up the street one block to leave it on the girl's porch. Her name's Makadie. I pin a wireless mic to him.
Ezri指出这看起来不像海盗标，更像膀胱感染。宝藏标记好并埋在雪里后，Ivan拿着铲子和便条，沿着街道走了一个街区，把它留在了女孩的门廊上。她叫Makadie。我给他别了一个无线麦克风。
OK, I'm now walking up to her doorstep. Just gonna set this here. OK. We've got a shovel set down by her door. I'm just gonna open up the glass thing, hit her doorbell, and knock. Now, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, running, running, running.
好了，我现在走向她的门前。就把这个放在这里。好吧。我们在她门边放了一把铲子。我只要打开玻璃门，按下门铃，然后敲门。现在，我跑，我跑，我跑，我跑，我跑，我跑，我跑。
Fast forward 36 seconds.
快进36秒。
OK, in the car.
好了，在车里。
There's a big SUV between our car and the path that Makadie's going to walk to the park. So if we all stay low, it's possible Makadie will not notice that we're here. And so we all crouch down, and we take turns peeking, to see if she's coming.
我们车和Makadie去公园的小路之间有一辆大型SUV。所以如果我们都压低身子，Makadie很有可能不会注意到我们在这里。于是我们都蹲下来，轮流探头看她有没有来。
Oh, I see her. I see her. She's right there. Yeah, OK. She's leaving her house, isn't she? Yeah. Yeah, she's got the shovel. Oh, oh, yeah. Well, she's looking around. She doesn't know which way to go. Dang it. I hope she guesses right. She doesn't know which way to go.
噢，我看见她了。我看见她了。她就在那儿。是的，好吧。她正从家里出来，对吧？是的。是的，她拿到了铲子。噢，噢，是的。好吧，她正在四处张望。她不知道该往哪走。该死。我希望她能猜对。她不知道往哪走。
Wait, we didn't include that in the note?
等等，我们没在便条里写这个？
Well, it didn't rhyme, OK?
好吧，它没押韵，好吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wait, nowhere in the note did we say "go to the park?"
等等，便条里没有任何地方说“去公园”？
Someone send her a text. Ezri, send her a text. Just tell her, "go south." Oh, she's figuring it out.
有人给她发个短信。Ezri，给她发条短信。就告诉她，“往南走”。噢，她正在弄明白。
Makadie and her sister walk towards us and the park. They get closer and closer. We are all as low in the car as we can be.
Makadie和她的妹妹走向我们和公园。她们越来越近。我们都在车里尽量压低身子。
Ira, think you have the best angle. Can you see? Is she there?
Ira，我觉得你的角度最好。你能看见吗？她在那里吗？
I can't see if she's in the parking lot. So to see what's happening, Kylie, who's in the driver's seat, takes the little square mirror that she got at Walmart to check her eyebrows during the day, and thrusts it in the air like a periscope above the steering wheel, and then--
我看不见她是否在停车场。为了看看发生了什么，坐在驾驶座上的Kylie拿起她从沃尔玛买来的小方镜，用来查看眉毛的那个，像潜望镜一样在方向盘上方伸向空中，然后——
[HONK]
[喇叭声]
[SCREAM]
[尖叫声]
Kylie!
Kylie！
Hits the horn.
按了喇叭。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Stay down, stay down.
蹲下，蹲下。
She's coming for us!
她冲我们来了！
No, no. OK, Kylie, drive us away.
不，不。好了，Kylie，快把我们开走。
She's coming for us.
她冲我们来了。
Get down, Ivan.
趴下，Ivan。
I'm down, I'm down. I'm hiding.
我趴下了，我趴下了。我躲着呢。
We pull out past a very confused looking Makadie and her sister, cruise up the street. Kylie repeats how sorry she is in between laughing. Ivan looks out the rear window at the park.
我们开过看起来非常困惑的Makadie和她的妹妹身边，沿着街道巡游。Kylie在笑声之间不停说对不起。Ivan从后窗看向公园。
Look, look, they're finding it. I think they're finding it.
看，看，她们找到了。我想她们找到了。
It this more fun than the actual dance?
这比真正的舞会更有趣吗？
Yes. It really is. I mean, in this case, the dance is not going to compare.
是的。真的是。我的意思是，在这种情况下，舞会无法相提并论。
This has been quite an experience.
这真是一次难忘的经历。
It's just so fun to get it together and then have all those embarrassing, scary, anxious moments. I don't know. It's fun. It's the best part.
把这些准备好，然后经历那些尴尬、害怕、焦虑的时刻，真的很有趣。我不知道。这很有趣。这是最棒的部分。
Other kids I talked to said the same thing. In fact, the elaborateness of these stunts does not necessarily mean that the kids feel strongly about the person the stunt is for. The guy who kidnapped the girl and dressed in a Batman costume to stage a fake rescue? She and he both told me it was not romantic between them. They don't even like each other as more than friends. He and his buddies just thought it would be cool to stage a kidnapping.
我采访的其他孩子也说了同样的话。事实上，这些噱头的精心策划并不一定意味着孩子们对受赠者有强烈的情感。那个绑架女孩并穿上蝙蝠侠服装上演假营救的家伙？她和我都在告诉我，他们之间并没有浪漫关系。他们甚至连好朋友都算不上。他和他的哥们儿只是觉得搞一场绑架很有趣。
Well, today on our program, we have stories of grand gestures, and so many of them are like that. They're an end in themselves. Even when they seem like they're trying so hard to say they're about love, and devotion, and some beloved person. From WBEZ Chicago. Oh wait, I do not need to say this myself. Can you say this for me? "From WBEZ Chicago?"
今天在节目中，我们有关于盛大姿态的故事，其中很多都是这样的。它们本身就是目的。即使当它们看起来像是试图努力证明关于爱、奉献和某个心爱的人时。来自芝加哥WBEZ。噢等等，我不需要自己说这个。你能帮我说吗？“来自芝加哥WBEZ？”
From WBEZ Chicago.
来自芝加哥WBEZ。
It's This American Life.
这是《美国生活》。
I'm Ira Glass.
我是Ira Glass。
Stay with us.
请继续收听。
That was good. That was good. OK, we'll start the show right there.
那很好。那很好。好吧，我们就在那里开始节目。
Act one, Dr. Strangelove. OK, this first story is about a guy who goes so far in his grand gestures that I need to say before we start, this story is not for kids. OK? Here's Miki Meek.
第一幕，奇爱博士。好吧，第一个故事是关于一个在盛大姿态中走得太远的家伙，我得在开始前说明，这个故事不适合孩子。好吧？这是Miki Meek。
I have a pile of newspaper articles about the story I'm going to tell you. It's a love story from Florida in the 1940s. The papers went nuts for this story. It's about a man who loved a woman so much that he never got over her death. The Miami Herald at the time ran their love story across the front page.
我有一堆关于我要讲的这个故事的报纸文章。这是一个发生在1940年代佛罗里达州的爱情故事。报纸为这个故事疯狂了。这是一个男人太爱一个女人，以至于无法从她的死亡中走出来的故事。当时的《迈阿密先驱报》把他们的爱情故事放在了头版。
The man's name is Carl von Cosel. There's a giant photo of him, where he looks charming and fragile in a white suit. Right next to that is a photo of Elena Hoyos in her wedding dress and a tiara. Her hair is in perfect black ringlets. She's beaming.
这个男人的名字叫Carl von Cosel。有一张他的巨幅照片，他看起来迷人而脆弱，穿着白色西装。旁边就是Elena Hoyos穿着婚纱戴着皇冠的照片。她的头发是完美的黑色卷发。她容光焕发。
Elena died young. She was just 22. After her death, Von Cosel visited her grave every day and brought flowers. He built her a fancy mausoleum with a dome, surrounded by palm trees and flower pots.
Elena英年早逝。她才22岁。她死后，Von Cosel每天都去她的墓前献花。他为她建了一座带圆顶的豪华陵墓，周围种满了棕榈树和花盆。
And then this is the thing that made it a news story. Von Cosel stole her body from her grave, and then kept her in his house for seven years.
然后就是这件事让它成了一个新闻故事。Von Cosel从坟墓里偷走了她的尸体，然后在家里藏了七年。
From the time von Cosel first met Elena, he launched into a series of grand gestures, each bigger than the previous, until he went too far.
从Von Cosel第一次见到Elena开始，他就展开了一系列盛大的姿态，每一个都比上一个更大，直到他做得太过火。
They first met at the hospital in Key West. Von Cosel was an x-ray technician, and Elena was 20 years old and sick with tuberculosis. Back in the '30s, TB killed a lot of people. There was no cure.
他们最初是在基韦斯特的医院见面的。Von Cosel是一名X光技师，而Elena当时20岁，患有肺结核。在30年代，肺结核夺走了许多人的生命。没有治愈方法。
I talked to a guy named Ben Harrison. He wrote a book about the two of them. He lives in Key West and got curious about the case when he moved there. He says that von Cosel fell in love with Elena right away.
我和一个叫Ben Harrison的人谈过。他写了一本关于他们两人的书。他住在基韦斯特，搬到那里时对这个案子感到好奇。他说Von Cosel对Elena一见钟情。
She apparently was strikingly beautiful. He took a blood sample from her finger. Normally, he would take it from a patient's ear, but hers was far too lovely to mar.
她显然长得惊人地漂亮。他从她的手指上取了血样。通常情况下，他会从病人的耳朵上取，但她的手指太美了，他不忍破坏。
Is that what he said?
他是这么说的吗？
Yes these are in his journals, that he didn't want to in any way disfigure her beauty.
是的，这些都在他的日记里，他不想以任何方式毁掉她的美。
This was the kind of guy von Cosel was. He wrote a memoir, where he said things like he didn't want to disfigure Elena's beauty, and that her voice sounded like a mockingbird's song in spring. He considered himself a scientist/inventor and claimed to have multiple university degrees in subjects like chemistry, philosophy, and physics, although Ben says he never could verify any of that.
这就是Von Cosel那种人。他写了一本回忆录，说了一些诸如他不想毁掉Elena的美，她的声音听起来像春天里的知更鸟歌声。他自认为是科学家/发明家，并声称拥有化学、哲学和物理学等学科的多个大学学位，尽管Ben说他从来无法证实这些。
He told me von Cosel's first grand gesture is telling Elena, sure, science hasn't developed a cure for TB, but--
他告诉我Von Cosel的第一个盛大姿态是告诉Elena，当然，科学还没研发出治愈肺结核的方法，但是——
Not to worry. He has revolutionary new cures, and he will cure her.
别担心。他有革命性的新疗法，他会治好她。
And what were they? I mean, how was he going to cure her?
它们是什么？我的意思是，他打算怎么治好她？
Well, he at first started radiation treatments there at the hospital. Then, as her illness progressed, he came by and started treating her in her home. He made this Frankenstein-ish electrical contraption.
好吧，他最初在医院开始了放射治疗。然后，随着病情恶化，他上门并在她家中开始治疗。他制造了这个科学怪人般的电气装置。
What did it look like?
它看起来是什么样的？
It looked like a big globe, and it had sparks inside. And he put electrodes on her chest, and they would shock her. He claimed that this put thousands of neutrons in the air, billions of neutrons in the air. And these were going to help cure her.
它看起来像个大球，里面有火花。他在她的胸前放了电极，会电击她。他声称这把数千个中子散布在空气中，数十亿个中子在空气中。这些将有助于治愈她。
This gets weirder and weirder.
这越来越奇怪了。
It was pure nonsense. It was just not going to work.
这纯粹是无稽之谈。根本不会起作用。
Did she want the treatments, though?
不过她想要这些治疗吗？
I mean, there was just nobody else who offered any hope whatsoever. So this was her only chance, because he was the only one offering a silver bullet.
我的意思是，根本没有人提供任何希望。所以这是她唯一的选择，因为他是唯一一个提供银弹的人。
Von Cosel was full of confidence about his own abilities. For example, he was trying to fix up a broken airplane he'd parked behind the hospital. It didn't have wings. He lived inside it. He was a German immigrant in his 50s, with a trim beard and wire-rim spectacles, walking around town, wearing all white, and carrying a cane.
Von Cosel对自己能力充满信心。例如，他试图修理一架停在医院后面的破飞机。它没有机翼。他住在里面。他是一个50多岁的德国移民，留着整齐的胡须，戴着钢丝边眼镜，穿着全白衣服，拿着拐杖走在镇上。
So far, their story has the makings of a great tragic love story. He loved her on sight. She was sick with an incurable disease that he'd do anything to cure. But there's one detail most of the newspapers left out. She never loved him.
到目前为止，他们的故事具备了伟大悲剧爱情故事的要素。他一见钟情。她患有不治之症，他会竭尽所能去治愈。但大多数报纸漏掉了一个细节。她从未爱过他。
Elena was actually married to another guy. But after she got sick, he left her. So she moved back in with her family. They didn't have a lot of money.
Elena其实嫁给了别人。但在她生病后，他离开了她。所以她搬回了家。他们没多少钱。
Von Cosel pursued Elena with the same arrogance and optimism he did everything else, giving her gifts, jewelry, a catalog where he told her to pick out whatever she wanted. But Elena's sister, Nana Medina, says it wasn't mutual.
Von Cosel以同样的傲慢和乐观追求Elena，给她送礼物、珠宝、一本目录，告诉她随便挑选她想要的东西。但Elena的姐姐Nana Medina说这不是双向的。
She gave a long interview to the Miami Herald, where she said, quote, "She never loved him. She was only nice to him because my mother told her she should be kind to those who were kind to her. She looked upon von Cosel as a grandfather. And when he proposed marriage, she always told him 'You are too old. Why, you are old enough to be my grandfather. What's more, I do not love you.' He became so persistent that we asked him to stay away from the house."
她在接受《迈阿密先驱报》的长篇采访时说，引述：“她从没爱过他。她对他友善只是因为我母亲告诉她，应该善待那些善待她的人。她把Von Cosel视为祖父。当他求婚时，她总是告诉他‘你太老了。为什么，你老得足以做我的祖父。而且，我不爱你。’他变得如此执着，以至于我们要求他远离我们的房子。”
Elena died about a year and a half after she met von Cosel. When he heard the news, he rushed across town to be by her side. Here's how he wrote about it in his memoir.
Elena在遇见Von Cosel大约一年半后去世了。当他听到消息，他赶忙穿过城镇去陪伴她。这是他在回忆录中写下的经过。
I went down to my knees before the bed. Elena's jaw had dropped, but her eyes were bright and clear. They had a faraway look. And as I gazed into those beloved eyes, they seemed to become deeper and deeper, like wells, which, with magnetic power, drew me in. I could not tear my eyes away from her. I could look forever. My poor, darling Elena.
我在床前跪下。Elena的下巴垂了下来，但她的眼睛明亮而清澈。它们带着一种遥远的目光。当我凝视那些深爱的眼睛时，它们似乎变得越来越深，就像一口井，带着磁性的力量，把我吸了进去。我无法将目光从她身上移开。我可以永远这样看着。我可怜的、亲爱的Elena。
So many of Von Cosel's choices during this period of time illustrate just how thin the line is between romantic and creepy. Gestures that seem romantic when someone loves you immediately flip to disturbing when they don't. Von Cosel paid for Elena's burial and for a headstone, which did not include her married name on it. But it did have his name inscribed on the lower half. Again, here's Ben.
Von Cosel在这段时间里的许多选择都说明了浪漫和怪异之间的界限有多么模糊。当有人爱你时，那些看似浪漫的姿态在别人不爱你时会瞬间翻转为令人不安。Von Cosel支付了Elena的葬礼费和墓碑费，上面没写她的夫姓。但确实在下半部分刻上了他的名字。再一次，这是Ben。
Because for one, her married name is Mesa, and he wasn't about to put her married name on a headstone that he had bought.
因为一方面，她的夫姓是Mesa，他才不会把她的夫姓刻在他买的墓碑上。
On his daily visit to Elena's grave, von Cosel starts worrying about rainwater seeping into her casket, and convinces the family to pull it from the ground. He begins building a mausoleum.
在他每天去Elena墓地的访问中，Von Cosel开始担心雨水渗入棺材，并说服家人将其从地下挖出。他开始建造一座陵墓。
Von Cosel talks to the funeral director, or the night watchman, or whoever, that he needs to come in and rebed her body.
Von Cosel告诉殡仪馆馆长或夜间看守，或者任何人，他需要进去重新安顿她的尸体。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
She's been dead for long enough so that she's decomposing. And he is very upset, because he claimed the mortician didn't follow his instructions as far as embalming goes. And so he puts new cloth on it, and cleans up the casket, and he takes off the dress she was buried in.
她死了很久了，所以她在腐烂。他非常不安，因为他声称殡仪员没有遵循他的防腐说明。所以他给它换上新布，清理棺材，脱掉她被埋葬时穿的裙子。
Man.
天哪。
Because it's rotted, and replaces it with cloth, and I think he put some new felt underneath her. He loved her that much.
因为它烂了，换成了布，我想他在她下面放了一些新毛毡。他就是那么爱她。
That's one way to describe it.
这是描述它的方式之一。
Yeah. And he was becoming more and more delusional.
是的。而且他变得越来越妄想。
Elena, of course, didn't ask for any of this. She didn't love him. She's paradoxically at the center of this story and utterly left out. Still, von Cosel kept going. He put Elena in a double casket. That's one casket inside of another. He said he wanted to protect her.
当然，Elena没要求这一切。她不爱他。她在这个故事的中心反倒是一个悖论，完全被排除在外。尽管如此，Von Cosel还是继续做下去。他把Elena装进双层棺材。就是一个棺材套在另一个里面。他说他想保护她。
I really don't think he accepted the fact that she was dead. I think he still felt she was alive, because I think he had valves on this thing.
我真的不认为他接受了她已经死了的事实。我认为他仍然觉得她活着，因为我认为他在这个东西上装了阀门。
For what?
为了什么？
So he could speak with her directly into the casket.
这样他就能直接对着棺材跟她说话。
He wrote in his memoir that, to him, these weren't one way conversations. He would sit there in the mausoleum, and talk to her, and she spoke back to him, and sang.
他在回忆录中写道，对他来说，这些不是单向对话。他会坐在陵墓里，跟她说话，而她也回应他，并唱歌。
Ever since the moon began to wane, Elena had begun to sing in her casket with a very soft, clear voice, which became just a little stronger from night to night. It was always the same old Spanish song about a lover who opens the grave of his dead bride. I could distinctly hear and understand every word.
自从月亮开始亏缺，Elena就开始在棺材里用非常柔软、清晰的声音唱歌，声音从晚上到晚上变得稍微强了一点。那总是同一首关于一个恋人打开死去的未婚妻坟墓的古老西班牙歌曲。我能清楚地听到并理解每一个字。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语歌唱]
The song is a Cuban bolero called "Black Wedding." Ben found out it was one of Elena's favorites after talking to her friends. Presumably, von Cosel knew this too.
这首歌是一首名为“黑色婚礼”的古巴波莱罗舞曲。Ben在和她的朋友交谈后发现这是Elena的最爱之一。据推测，Von Cosel也知道这一点。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语歌唱]
I asked Ben to translate some of the lyrics for me.
我请Ben为我翻译了一些歌词。
A young man's lover died before their wedding. Without her love, he simply could not reason. At night, he would visit the graveyard and dream about the days she was alive.
一个年轻人的恋人在婚礼前去世了。没有了她的爱，他简直无法理智。夜晚，他会去墓地，梦见她还活着的日子。
His tears would fall upon her tombstone, the tombstone of the girl to be his bride. On a night when thunder roared and lightning flashed, he broke apart the tombstone of her grave. And with his hands, he dug into the earth, and in his arms, he carried her away. By a flickering funeral candlelight, on his bed that flowers covered, he gently laid the body of his sweetheart, and said his wedding vows to his dead lover.
他的泪水落在她的墓碑上，那个即将成为他新娘的女孩的墓碑上。在一个雷声轰鸣、闪电闪烁的夜晚，他打碎了她坟墓的墓碑。用他的双手，他挖掘大地，并将她抱在怀里。在闪烁的葬礼烛光下，在他鲜花覆盖的床上，他轻轻地放下了心上人的尸体，并向他死去的爱人许下了婚礼誓言。
The song was written to be tongue in cheek, ironic and inappropriate, but von Cosel took it literally, as inspiration for everything he's about to do next.
这首歌本来是幽默、讽刺和不恰当的，但Von Cosel却把它当真了，作为他接下来要做的一切的灵感。
According to von Cosel, this is her plea for him to please take her home with him, the same way the distraught lover does in the song.
据Von Cosel说，这是她的恳求，让他把她带回家，就像歌中那位心烦意乱的恋人所做的一样。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语歌唱]
Von Cosel wrote that he waited for a new moon, got a wagon, and stole the casket. He brought Elena home, and tried to repair her decomposed body.
Von Cosel写道，他等待新月，弄了一辆马车，偷走了棺材。他把Elena带回家，并试图修复她腐烂的尸体。
Her face was in such poor shape that he had to do something, and so he put on this gauze wax concoction, and fastened it to what was left of her face.
她的脸状况太差，他必须做点什么，所以他涂上了这种纱布蜡混合物，固定在她脸部残余的地方。
He did this to the rest of her body too, inserted glass eyes and painted on eyebrows. Von Cosel hadn't been deterred by what Elena wanted back when she was alive. Now that he had her dead body in his home, he could play house, dress her up, have sex with her. And he did all of those things.
他也对她的身体的其他部分做了同样的事，插入玻璃眼睛，画上眉毛。Von Cosel在Elena活着的时候并没有被她的意愿所阻碍。现在他家里有她的尸体，他可以玩过家家，给她穿衣服，和她发生性关系。他做了所有这些事。
He wrote in his memoir that he made Elena breakfast, eggs and a cup of Lipton tea. He filled the vases next to her bed with flowers and sometimes just talked to her about the weather.
他在回忆录中写道，他给Elena做了早餐，鸡蛋和一杯立顿茶。他给床边的花瓶插上花，有时只是跟她谈论天气。
She was kind of his living doll, there in their little household. And they celebrated Christmas together, and he put a Christmas tree there, and put 13 candles and said he played his organ to her until the candles burned down.
她在他们的小家庭里成了某种活着的娃娃。他们一起庆祝圣诞节，他放了一棵圣诞树，点了13根蜡烛，说他为她弹奏风琴直到蜡烛烧尽。
This went on for seven years. He also conducted experiments to try to bring Elena back from the dead. In his memoir, he wrote that he gave her radiation treatments, and submerged her in a tank filled with quote, plasma fluid.
这种情况持续了七年。他还进行了实验，试图让Elena起死回生。他在回忆录中写道，他给她做放射治疗，并把她浸没在一个装满了所谓“血浆液体”的罐子里。
Eventually, Elena's sister, Nana Medina, started to suspect that something was up. There were rumors. And she asked von Cosel to open Elena's mausoleum for her, but he refused. So one day, Nana showed up at his house.
最终，Elena的姐姐Nana Medina开始怀疑出了什么事。有传言。她要求Von Cosel为她打开Elena的陵墓，但他拒绝了。所以有一天，Nana出现在他家。
Well, she walks in and sees this effigy, this Elena, in a sort of wedding, gauze wedding thing lying on the bed. I mean, as she describes it, it was the most horrific thing she'd ever seen in her life. But as upset as she was, she said, if you will take the body back and put it in there, we'll just let this go.
好吧，她走进去看到了这个雕像，这个Elena，穿着某种婚纱，纱布婚礼的东西躺在床上。我的意思是，据她描述，这是她一生中见过的最可怕的事情。但尽管她很不安，她说，如果你把尸体带回去放回那里，我们就让这件事过去。
Von Cosel didn't return the body, so she went to the Key West police. They arrived at his house in a motorcade, and von Cosel confessed immediately.
Von Cosel没有归还尸体，所以她去了基韦斯特警察局。他们驱车来到他家，Von Cosel立即承认了。
And that's when the gifts started arriving at the jailhouse. People brought him fruit, cookies, and hot tea. They serenaded him at night. A group of women from Tampa brought him money. Locals posted his bond. An attorney took on his case pro bono.
然后礼物开始涌向监狱。人们给他带来水果、饼干和热茶。他们在晚上为他唱小夜曲。一群来自坦帕的妇女给他寄了钱。当地人交了保释金。一位律师免费接了他的案子。
People were captivated by this story. A newspaper quoted von Cosel saying, "I did not want one so beautiful to go to dust." A radio station in Havana ran a soap opera about Elena and von Cosel's great romance.
人们被这个故事迷住了。一家报纸引用Von Cosel的话说：“我不希望如此美丽的人化为尘土。”哈瓦那的一家广播电台制作了一部关于Elena和Von Cosel伟大爱情的肥皂剧。
He was in love with her? OK, he was in love with her and he wanted to make her better.
他爱她？好吧，他爱她，他想让她好起来。
This is Ida Roberts. Her mom was good friends with Elena, lived down the street from her. I talked to her for a while about this question. How could people see this as a romantic story?
这是Ida Roberts。她妈妈和Elena是好朋友，住在她街对面。我和她聊了这个问题一会儿。人们怎么会把这看作一个浪漫的故事？
Well, for starters, Ida's mom didn't know at the time that von Cosel was having sex with Elena's corpse. There were rumors, but the truth didn't come out for decades, when a doctor from her autopsy wrote about it in a medical journal. But still, that doesn't change the story so much for Ida.
好吧，首先，Ida的妈妈当时不知道Von Cosel在和Elena的尸体发生性关系。有传言，但真相在几十年后才出来，当时一位负责尸检的医生把它写在了一份医学杂志上。但即便如此，这对Ida来说并没有改变故事多少。
My mother knew Maria Elena. And because she accepted him, my mother had no problem was with what he did.
我母亲认识Maria Elena。因为她接受了他，我母亲对他所做的事没有意见。
I mean, was your mom upset that he had had the body for so long?
我的意思是，你妈妈对他拥有尸体这么久感到不安吗？
No.
没有。
Really?
真的吗？
She was not upset.
她没感到不安。
But isn't there something also later? The autopsy report came out he was having sexual relations with her, or attempting to?
但是后来不是有什么吗？尸检报告出来了，他正在和她发生性关系，或者尝试这样做？
Well, I guess he was in love with her, and he made love to her. And he didn't care whether she was dead or not. In fact, he never-- he never wanted to think that she was dead. He wanted to think that she was coming back. She was asleep.
好吧，我想他是爱她的，他跟她做爱。他不在乎她是否死了。事实上，他从来——他从来不想认为她死了。他想认为她会回来的。她睡着了。
I think, Ida, you are a very hard person to shock.
Ida，我觉得你是一个很难被震惊的人。
Yeah, mhm. Just remember, this was a very small town and very close. Everybody was very close. And I believe that's the way, laid back in Key West like we are, we just accept things.
是的，嗯。记住，这是一个非常小的城镇，非常亲密。每个人都非常亲密。我相信这就是方式，在基韦斯特像我们这样随和，我们只是接受事情。
I heard this from a lot of people I interviewed down there-- live and let live. They take pride in their history of being home to people who didn't fit in-- bootleggers, drug smugglers, people who dropped off the grid.
我在那里采访的许多人也听到了这个——活并让别人活。他们为自己家乡是那些不合群的人的家园而自豪——私酒贩子、毒品走私者、被遗忘的人。
But Ida's pretty straight. We talked in her office at a Catholic school in Key West. She's the director of Religious Education for kids there and looks like somebody's nice grandma.
但Ida很正派。我们在基韦斯特的一所天主教学校的办公室里谈话。她是那里的宗教教育主任，看起来就像某人的和蔼奶奶。
When you look at this story now, the story of von Cosel, I mean, do you view it as romantic or completely nuts?
当你现在看着这个故事，Von Cosel的故事，我的意思是，你认为它是浪漫的还是完全疯了？
I think it's a nice love story. I do. I wouldn't have any bad thing to say about him. [CHUCKLING]
我认为这是一个很好的爱情故事。我确实这么认为。我对他没有什么坏话可说。[轻笑]
Why is that? Explain that.
为什么呢？解释一下。
Because he was in love with her. I mean, he was eccentric of course, you know crazy thoughts he had, but I mean, he wasn't there to abuse her or anything. You know, I mean--
因为他爱她。我的意思是，他当然很古怪，你知道他有疯狂的想法，但我的意思是，他不是为了虐待她什么的。你知道，我的意思是——
According the record, he was.
根据记录，他是。
Wait, but he didn't chop her up and throw her in the ocean or anything, like a lot of people have done, you know? A lot of spouses. But he took good care of her. And he wanted-- he just didn't want to let go.
等等，但他没有把她剁碎扔进大海什么的，像很多人做的那样，你知道？很多配偶。但他很好地照顾了她。而且他想要——他只是不想放手。
I mean, definitely selfish, though. In a lot of ways, I mean, he's doing what he wants to do, and not necessarily what the family would have wanted her to do-- wanted him to do, or even Elena.
我的意思是，这确实很自私。在很多方面，我的意思是，他做他想做的事，而不一定是他家人想要她做的——想要他做的，甚至Elena也想要他做的。
Love is like that. Love is kind of selfish, isn't it? When you find somebody you want, you want them regardless.
爱情就是那样。爱情有点自私，不是吗？当你找到你想要的人，无论如何你都想要他们。
Love is an excuse for all sorts of behavior. I can understand why so many people wanted to believe this version of the story. It's much easier and nicer to see this as a grand gesture of a lovesick man than the abuse of a delusional pervert.
爱是各种行为的借口。我能理解为什么那么多人想相信这个版本的故事。将其看作一个情痴男人的盛大姿态，远比看作一个妄想变态者的虐待要容易和美好得多。
In the end, the charges against von Cosel were dropped. The court looked into whether he was insane and decided no. They called his obsession with Elena a quirk.
最后，对Von Cosel的指控被撤销了。法院调查了他是否精神失常并决定没有。他们称他对Elena的迷恋为一个怪癖。
Even when the public was presented with physical proof, Elena's body, they chose to see the story this way. After police took Elena's body from von Cosel, the funeral home, incredibly, put her out on display, probably without the family's permission.
即使在公众被提供了实物证据、Elena的尸体时，他们还是选择了这样看待这个故事。在警察从Von Cosel那里带走Elena的尸体后，殡仪馆令人难以置信地把她展示出来，可能是在未经家人允许的情况下。
It was a big crowd that day, I think, and we just followed the crowd.
那天人很多，我想，我们只是跟着人群走。
That's Don Carbonell. He was a kid at the time and lived across the street from the funeral home. There's actually a photo of Don in the newspaper spread, standing in a big crowd right behind Elena's body.
那是Don Carbonell。他当时还是个孩子，住在殡仪馆街对面。在报纸的通栏里实际上有一张Don的照片，站在人群中，就在Elena尸体的后面。
I might have even been playing in the yard with Frank, whose father owned the funeral home at the time. And they opened the embalming room doors.
我可能甚至在院子里和Frank玩，当时他的父亲拥有那家殡仪馆。他们打开了防腐室的门。
And how close did you get?
你离得有多近？
I was probably six to ten feet away from the table that they had her laid up on.
我离他们放置她的桌子大约六到十英尺。
And what do you remember? Do you remember what she looked like?
你记得什么？你记得她看起来像什么吗？
Yeah, vaguely, I remember. She had glassy eyes, and she just-- she didn't look real. She didn't look real. Looked like maybe somebody made up a body. That's the way she had impressed me. You'd say a big, overgrown doll.
是的，模糊地记得。她有玻璃般的眼睛，她只是——她看起来不像真的。她看起来不像真的。看起来像是有人伪造了一具尸体。那就是她给我的印象。你会说一个巨大的、过大的娃娃。
The newspaper articles quoted people who said she looked beautiful. "Von Cosel did such a good job preserving her." One woman wrote a letter saying, "they should enclose Elena in a glass case and turn her into a Sleeping Beauty attraction." Which is basically what's happened to Elena and her story today.
报纸文章引用人们的话说她看起来很美。“Von Cosel做得真好，保护得真好。”一位女士写信说，“他们应该把Elena装在玻璃柜里，把她变成一个睡美人景点。”这就是基本上现在Elena和她的故事所发生的事情。
All right, our story takes place here in 1930, and involves this young girl right here.
好吧，我们的故事发生在这里，1930年，涉及这年轻女孩。
This is from a trolley tour of Key West for tourists these days. All the disturbing facts of the story are now out. And our ideas about sex and men and women are dramatically different. But listen to this. They still tell this story as a romance, for the same reason people did in the '40s. They like it.
这是如今基韦斯特游客的电车之旅。这个故事所有令人不安的事实现在都出来了。我们关于性、男人和女人的观念大不相同。但听听这个。他们仍然把这个故事当作浪漫传说，原因和40年代人们做的一样。他们喜欢它。
Well, I thought we'd discuss a love story, an undying love story, a story that involves grave robbing and a corpse bride. Who's interested? All right, good.
好吧，我想我们要讨论一个爱情故事，一个不朽的爱情故事，一个涉及盗墓和尸体新娘的故事。谁感兴趣？好的，很好。
And here's another.
这是另一个。
By show of hands, how many of you believe in true love? Just trying to set up this next tale-- this is a tale of true love, Key Weird style with a twist. It starts with a gentleman by the name of Count Karl von Cosel. Enter into the picture a beautiful Cuban girl. Her name is Elena.
举手表决，有多少人相信真爱？只是想引出下一个故事——这是一个关于真爱的故事，基韦斯特风味的，带点曲折。它始于一位名叫Karl von Cosel伯爵的绅士。进入画面的是一个美丽的古巴女孩。她的名字是Elena。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐响起]
Miki Meek, Payson High School class of none of your business, is one of the producers of our program. John Ellison Conlee read the excerpts of von Cosel's memoir. Ben Harrison's book about von Cosel is called Undying Love.
Miki Meek，佩森高中非你管班，是我们节目的制作人之一。John Ellison Conlee朗读了Von Cosel回忆录的摘录。Ben Harrison关于Von Cosel的书叫《不朽的爱》。
Coming up, what happens when sky writers make mistakes, and a few grand gestures that actually go right. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，当空中文字写错时会发生什么，还有一些真正做对了的盛大姿态。那就在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose a theme, bringing you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's show, as we watch Valentine's Day recede into the rearview mirror of our lives, our theme is grand gestures, stories of people who go all out, and what it means when they do. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act 2, Say It Out Cloud.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，当我们看着情人节消逝在我们生活的后视镜中，我们的主题是盛大姿态，关于那些全力以赴的人们的故事，以及当他们这样做时意味着什么。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，大声说出来。
One of our producers, David Kestenbaum, spoke with some people who are in the grand gesture business. I'm talking about sky writers.
我们的制作人之一，David Kestenbaum，与一些从事盛大姿态业务的人交谈。我说的是空中文字写作者。
Every sky writer I talked to you had a story of some odd message they'd put in the sky. Someone paid for a cartoon cloud to be drawn in the sky, with little lines for rain. And then there was the message that was just numbers, 3.1415 etc. Get it? Pi in the sky.
我交谈过的每一位空中文字写作者都有一个他们写在天上的奇怪信息的故事。有人花钱让人在天上画了一朵卡通云，带几条雨线。然后还有一个全是数字的信息，3.1415等等。明白吗？空中的圆周率。
The comedian Kurt Braunohler recently hired a pilot to put up the skywriting message over Los Angeles that he'd always wanted to see. "How do I land?"
喜剧演员Kurt Braunohler最近雇了一名飞行员，在洛杉矶上空写下了他一直想看到的空中文字消息。“我怎么降落？”
Even a simple message can cost a couple of thousand dollars. And it doesn't last very long. Basically, as soon as it's written, it starts to fall apart. So a lot of the time, it's people with a pretty big emotion who want to write something in the sky.
即使是一个简单的信息也要花几千美元。而且持续时间不长。基本上，一旦写完，它就开始散开。所以很多时候，是那些情感非常强烈的人想在天上写点东西。
It was the woman that contacted me, and she couldn't-- it was a very secret love affair.
是一位女士联系我，她不能——那是一个非常秘密的婚外情。
This is Suzanne Asbury-Oliver. She's a longtime sky writer.
这是Suzanne Asbury-Oliver。她是一位资深的空中文字写作者。
And it couldn't be known that this relationship was happening.
而且不能让人知道这段关系正在发生。
Wow.
哇。
But she really wanted to express her commitment, almost in a public way that she couldn't in any other way. You know, shout out to the world "I love you and I'm with you forever." But nobody else can know.
但她真的想表达她的承诺，几乎是以一种她无法以任何其他方式表达的公开方式。你知道，向世界大声喊出“我爱你，我会永远和你在一起”。但没人能知道。
The message? A heart. No name, just initials, in the sky over a lake.
信息是什么？一颗心。没有名字，只有首字母，在湖泊上空的云层中。
It was just kind of sad and romantic all at the same time.
这既有点悲伤又浪漫。
Were they having an affair?
他们有婚外情吗？
Well, that was my guess.
好吧，那是我的猜测。
Yeah. How did it feel doing that one?
是的。做那个任务感觉如何？
Yeah, it was nice, you know? Letting somebody express a huge emotion.
是的，很棒，你知道吗？让人表达一种巨大的情感。
In clouds of smoke.
在烟雾云中。
Yeah, mile-high letters, 10,000 feet above the Earth.
是的，英里高的字母，地球上方10,000英尺。
Sky writing seems to satisfy some very basic urge. Essentially, as soon as we figured out how to fly, someone was like, "You know what? I'm gonna write giant letters in the sky." The first pilot did it in the 1920s, maybe even earlier. And the vast majority of personal messages seem to be essentially the same thing over and over.
空中文字写作似乎满足了一些非常基本的冲动。本质上，一旦我们弄清楚如何飞行，有人就想，“你知道吗？我要在天上写巨大的字母。”第一位飞行员在1920年代，甚至更早的时候就做到了。而且绝大多数个人信息看起来本质上都是一样的内容，一次又一次。
"Marry me," or "I love you," or a heart, or "I heart you." Here in New York, the usual spot is over Central Park. And it seems to be mostly guys who want to put messages of love in the sky. The male sky writers I talked to didn't have a lot of theories about why that was. But Suzanne did.
“嫁给我”，或者“我爱你”，或者一颗心，或者“我心你”。在纽约，通常的地点是在中央公园上空。而且似乎大多是想在天上留下爱的信息的男人。我交谈过的男性空中文字写作者对为什么会这样没什么理论。但Suzanne有。
Maybe men have a harder time expressing themselves? And want to say "I really, really, really do love you. I really, really do want you to marry me" in a really big way.
也许男人更难表达自己？并想用一种非常大的方式说“我真的、真的、真的爱你。我真的、真的非常想让你嫁给我。”
This is it. These are our airplanes.
就是这个。这些是我们的飞机。
Only a handful of people in the world do sky writing. It's this weirdly technical piece of flying. I went to visit Jim Record he's a pilot with a company called Skytypers out on Long Island. It was snowing out, so we weren't going up. But he showed me one of the planes.
世界上只有少数几个人会空中文字写作。这是一项奇怪的技术性飞行。我去拜访了Jim Record，他是长岛一家名为Skytypers公司的飞行员。外面在下雪，所以我们没上去。但他给我看了其中一架飞机。
OK, this is our lead airplane.
好吧，这是我们的领航飞机。
How do you get in? Climb up on the wing?
你是怎么进去的？爬上机翼？
[INAUDIBLE] yeah.
[听不清] 是的。
The plane looks like he stole it from a museum. It's a World War II plane, built in 1940. Imagine someone wearing goggles and a long scarf flying it, trying to shoot down another pilot. There's a spot on the wings where the machine guns would have been mounted. He let me climb in.
这架飞机看起来像是他从博物馆偷来的。这是一架二战时期的飞机，建于1940年。想象一下有人戴着护目镜和长围巾驾驶它，试图击落另一名飞行员。机翼上有一个地方曾经装有机枪。他让我爬了进去。
This just got super real.
这真的变得非常现实了。
Oh, it's real. Yeah, this got super real in a hurry.
噢，这是真的。是的，这很快变得非常现实。
And where's the button for the smoke?
烟雾按钮在哪里？
Right here.
就在这里。
Can I press it?
我可以按吗？
Sure
当然。
[CLICKING]
[咔哒声]
There's a very small fire extinguisher here.
这里有一个非常小的灭火器。
That fire extinguisher, if you can't put it out with that thing, then you jump out of the airplane.
那个灭火器，如果你不能用那个东西把它扑灭，那你就要跳出飞机了。
Jim's a former Navy pilot. He once applied to be an astronaut. Every skywriting job, he and the other pilots, they call it a mission.
Jim是一位前海军飞行员。他曾经申请成为宇航员。每一次空中写作任务，他和飞行员们都称之为任务。
From his perspective, the key to a successful marriage proposal is pre-mission planning. Because in order for the message to look right from the ground, he has to write it backward. That's how it looks to him up there. He's looking down, and everyone else is looking up. The order of the letters is backward for him, and the letters themselves are backward.
从他的角度来看，成功求婚的关键是任务前规划。因为为了让地面上的信息看起来正确，他必须倒着写。这就是他在上面看的样子。他向下看，每个人都在向上看。字母的顺序对他来说是相反的，字母本身也是相反的。
Jim says he tries not to think about that. It's just too confusing. So he'll break it down into a series of moves that he can just execute.
Jim说他尽量不去想这一点。太混乱了。所以他会把它分解成一系列他可以执行的动作。
M's are tough, because there's so much involved in an M. There's actually four different strokes in an M. And then the R's aren't all that easy either, because you do an R, and then you have to come around and go here, and you've got to come up and it comes down here again.
M很难，因为M里涉及的东西太多。M实际上有四种不同的笔画。R也不是那么容易，因为你要做一个R，然后你必须绕过来去这里，你必须上来，它又在这里下来。
"Marry me." Two M's, two R's. Jim will climb into this tiny plane with me "Marry me" or whatever mapped out on a piece of paper on a clipboard. When he's in the right spot, he makes sure the Arm Smoke switch has been flipped. Then he presses that little button under his thumb on the stick, and streaming out behind him is this giant tube of perfectly white, billowy smoke.
“嫁给我”。两个M，两个R。Jim会带着我和“嫁给我”或者随便什么写在纸夹板上的东西爬进这架小飞机。当他在正确的位置时，他确保ARM SMOKE开关已打开。然后他按下操纵杆拇指下的小按钮，在他身后 streaming 出来的是这根巨大的、完美纯白、滚滚的烟雾管。
To make sure the letters are the right length, he counts.
为了确保字母的长度正确，他会数数。
Smoke on, thousand one, thousand two, thousand three, thousand four. I start tightening the turn ups. Five, six--
烟雾打开，一千一，一千二，一千三，一千四。我开始收紧转弯。五，六——
He's describing how he draws a heart here, one side at a the time. He'll start at the top, where the two halves are going to come together, turning, turning, almost in a circle, then straightening out.
他正在描述他在这里如何画一颗心，一次画一半。他会从顶部开始，两半即将汇合的地方，转弯，转弯，几乎画一个圆，然后拉直。
15, 16, smoke off.
十五，十六，烟雾关闭。
Since his plane is, in effect, the tip of the pencil, Jim can't actually see how what he's writing looks. So when he's done half the heart, he'll pull back on the stick, and shoot up higher into the sky, to the point where the airplane almost stalls. He says at this point, he's upside down, looking down at the message, which, remember, is backward. Then he'll basically dive bomb back down and do the other half of the heart.
由于他的飞机实际上是铅笔尖，Jim实际上看不到他写的东西是什么样子。所以当他画完半个心时，他会向后拉操纵杆，冲向更高的天空，直到飞机几乎失速。他说在这一点上，他是倒立的，看着下方的消息，记住，那是倒着的。然后他基本上会俯冲下来做另一半心。
Are there are a lot of tight turns? Would I get sick?
有很多急转弯吗？我会晕吗？
It's all tight turns. Yes, you would get sick. It's not normal. You spend a lot of time upside down and backwards.
全是急转弯。是的，你会晕的。这不正常。你花很多时间倒立和倒着飞。
Do you ever screw up?
你有没有搞砸过？
Oh, yes. Unfortunately, I have.
噢，有。不幸的是，我有过。
One time-- he knows this is silly. One time, he made a mistake, and then went back to cross it out-- like flew across the whole message and laid down another line of smoke through what he'd written.
有一次——他知道这很傻。有一次，他犯了一个错误，然后回去划掉它——就像飞过整个信息并在他写的东西上又铺了一层烟雾。
Greg Stinis, another sky writer, told me he once mixed up two marriage proposals. He can't remember the names, but it was like, he wrote "Marry me, Sue," and the woman below was named Tabitha, and vice versa.
Greg Stinis，另一位空中文字写作者，告诉我他曾经弄混了两个求婚。他不记得名字了，就像是，他写了“嫁给我，Sue”，而下面的女人叫Tabitha，反之亦然。
Another time, he did this happy face over the Macy's Day parade in New York City. It looked great, but then the wind started to twist the face until it looked like a creepy demon. He flew back and forth through it, to try to get it to disperse, but it hung around for a long time.
还有一次，他在纽约梅西百货大游行上画了一个笑脸。看起来很棒，但风开始扭曲笑脸，直到它看起来像一个诡异的恶魔。他飞来飞去试图让它散开，但它悬挂了很长时间。
There are darker emotions people sometimes want to put in the sky. One pilot told me about a woman who thought her boyfriend was cheating on her. She wanted to write "I'm watching you" above his head. And Suzanne Asbury-Oliver, whose company, by the way, is Oliver's Flying Circus, told me about this request she got just last month.
人们有时想在天空中写一些更黑暗的情感。一位飞行员告诉我一位女士以为她的男朋友在欺骗她。她想在他头顶写“我在看着你”。而Suzanne Asbury-Oliver，顺便说一下，她的公司是Oliver's Flying Circus，告诉我她上个月收到的这个请求。
Yeah, I got a request, actually they wanted it over the inaugural. And it was "[BLEEP Trump."
是的，我收到了一个请求，实际上他们想在就职典礼上空写。内容是“[哔——]特朗普”。
She said no. And for all the marriage proposals sky writers get, Jim says there is also this one.
她说不。而且对于空中文字写作者收到的所有求婚，Jim说也有这么一个。
We've done one divorce. And the divorce message was, "She got it all."
我们做过一次离婚。离婚消息是，“她拥有了一切”。
That seem sad to you?
那对你来说显得悲伤吗？
No no. I can't say it did, since I've been divorced before. Everybody says the happiest times of a boat owner-- the day they buy it, and the day they sell it. I would think maybe a marriage would be like that-- the day you get married and the day you finally are not married.
不，不。我不能说它悲伤，因为我以前离婚过。每个人都说船主最幸福的时刻——买船的那一天，卖船的那一天。我想也许婚姻也是这样——结婚的那一天和你终于不再结婚的那一天。
Can you imagine the guy looking up and being like, I did it.
你能想象那个人抬头看说，我做到了。
It's a defiant stand. It's like, yes, but the last $5,000 you didn't get, because I put it into this message.
这是一种挑衅的立场。就像，是的，但你没得到的最后5000美元，因为我把它花在这个消息上了。
One emotion did seem kind of absent in all the stories I heard, for reasons that I totally get, because it's hard enough to do this in letters that aren't a mile high, which is to say "I'm sorry."
有一种情绪似乎在我听到的所有故事中都显得缺失，原因我完全明白，因为在非英里高的字母中做到这一点已经够难了，那就是说“对不起”。
Jim's boss, Larry Arken, did remember one like that. It was from years ago, but it stuck with him. The message "Pooh Bear, come home." They wrote it in two or three spots around New York.
Jim的老板Larry Arken确实记得一个类似的故事。那是几年前的了，但一直困扰着他。信息是“Pooh Bear，回家吧”。他们在纽约周围两三个地方写了它。
He thinks some guy's girlfriend or wife had left him. He doesn't know how it turned out. But I have a guess. I think when you are to the point of writing something like that, with giant letters in the sky, you are probably past the point where giant letters in the sky can help you.
他认为某个人的女朋友或妻子离开了他。他不知道结局如何。但我有一个猜测。我认为当你到了那种地步，在天空中用巨大的字母写下那样的东西时，你可能已经过了巨大字母能帮助你的地步了。
David Kestenbaum. [MUSIC PLAYING - "SKY WRITING"]
David Kestenbaum。[音乐响起——《空中写作》]
Act 3, It's Gesture Imagination. More than anybody on our staff, maybe more than anybody I've ever met, actually, one of our producers, Elna Baker, really, truly believed in the power of grand gestures. It was this kind of magical thinking that lasted well into adulthood for her, into her late 20s.
第三幕，这是姿态想象力。比我们团队中的任何人都多，也许比我见过的任何人都多，实际上，我们的制作人之一，Elna Baker，真的，真的相信盛大姿态的力量。这种神奇的思维在成年后，一直持续到她20多岁。
I believed that it was the surest way to show someone you love them or to win love.
我相信这是向某人展示你爱他们或赢得爱情的最可靠方式。
And a grand gesture could be, like, what?
盛大姿态可以是，比如，什么？
A declaration of love, like a speech, but in a very public manner. A giant cardboard sign. Showing someone that you especially knew them through a very special gift.
爱的宣言，像演讲，但以非常公开的方式。巨大的纸板标语。通过非常特别的礼物向某人展示你特别了解他们。
Elna grew up Mormon. And talking to her about how she loves grand gestures made me think of those kids from Payson High School. Remember them? We started today's program with them. Lots of those kids are Mormon. And the way they ask each other to dances at that school happens all over Utah. And it occurred to me, is there something about being young and Mormon and grand gestures that go together?
Elna是在摩门教中长大的。和她谈论她如何热爱盛大姿态让我想到佩森高中的那些孩子。还记得他们吗？我们今天节目的开头就是他们。那些孩子很多是摩门教徒。他们在学校邀请彼此参加舞会的方式在整个犹他州到处都在发生。我想到，摩门教徒和盛大姿态之间是不是有什么联系？
And this isn't something you could prove one way or another, but just to say it, you have these kids who are forbidden to drink or have sex. Maybe that's one reason that their feelings for each other play out with these elaborate schemes, right? And that made sense to Elna.
这不是你能证明什么，只是这么说，你有这些被禁止喝酒或发生性关系的孩子。也许这就是他们对彼此的情感通过这些复杂的计划发挥出来的一个原因，对吧？这对Elna来说很有道理。
Yeah. No, I definitely-- once I started having sex, I stopped doing grand gestures. Because I was like, oh, turns out you can just-- [MUMBLING] You know? You could just have sex with someone.
是的。不，我确实——一旦我开始有性生活，我就停止做盛大姿态了。因为我想，噢，事实证明你可以只是——[嘟囔] 你知道吗？你可以只是和某人发生性关系。
That made it weird dirtier, the way you just said that.
你刚才那么说让它变得很脏。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
OK.
好吧。
And I grew up on grand-- like my parents, the way my parents got together was-- I grew up on stories of grand gestures.
我是伴随着盛大——就像我的父母，我父母在一起的方式是——我伴随着盛大姿态的故事长大。
Oh, is that true?
噢，这是真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like what?
比如什么？
My dad and mom dated for about two and a half weeks. And my dad went to the Mormon temple, and he was just praying to see if he should date this woman. And he said that he heard the voices of his future children, like me and my brothers and sisters, and we were like, hurry, go, do it. Like, we want to be born.
我爸妈约会了大约两个半星期。我爸爸去了摩门教神庙，他只是在祈祷看他是否应该和这个女人约会。他说他听到了未来孩子的声音，像我和我的兄弟姐妹，我们就像，快，去，去做吧。就像，我们想出生。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. And he rushed out of the temple, went and found my mom, knocked on her door, brought her outside of her dorm. And in front of the dorm, there was a rock, like a big rock. And he made her stand on top of the rock. And then he knelt down and said, "Will you marry me?" And she said yes.
是的。他冲出神庙，找到我妈妈，敲开她的门，把她带到宿舍外面。在宿舍门前，有一块石头，像一块大石头。他让她站在石头上。然后他跪下说：“你愿意嫁给我吗？”她说愿意。
They'd been dating for two and a half weeks. They've known each other for four weeks. And my parents actually are very in love, and very happily married. And so I believed that love was like hearing a voice that basically told you this was right. And then you would do anything for that voice.
他们约会了两个半星期。他们认识彼此四个星期。我父母其实非常相爱，婚姻非常幸福。所以我相信爱就像听到了一个声音，基本上告诉你这是对的。然后你就会为那个声音做任何事。
And that's the attitude towards love Elna carried into adulthood. When she would talk to our friends about their romantic lives and situations, at some point, Elna would tell them, OK, here's what you have to do. You have to go big. And she'd give advice that, today, she thinks was totally wrong headed. Up until her 20s, she had no experience in love, had never had a real adult relationship, was completely naive about all of it.
这就是Elna带入成年后的爱情态度。当她和我们的朋友谈论他们的浪漫生活和处境时，在某个时候，Elna会告诉他们，好吧，这就是你要做的。你必须搞大。她会给建议，今天她认为那是完全错误方向的建议。直到20多岁，她没有爱情经验，从来没谈过真正的成年恋爱，对这一切完全幼稚。
But she still cheerfully jumped in with her advice. She encouraged her friend Nick to move to New York City to prove his love for a woman who had broken up with him and did not want his love. She convinced your friend Allie to give a guy that she'd just started seeing this giant birthday crown, homemade with fur and feathers and a star with his picture that kind of jumped off the crown. He never went out with Allie again.
但她仍然愉快地给建议。她鼓励她的朋友Nick搬到纽约去证明他对一个已经和他分手并不想要他爱的女人的爱。她劝说她的朋友Allie给一个刚开始约会的家伙这个巨大的生日王冠，自制的，有毛皮和羽毛，还有一颗带着他照片的星星，从王冠上弹出来。他再也没和Allie约会过。
When Elna's friend Louise regretted breaking up with her boyfriend, Gabe, and decided she wanted Gabe back, Elna suggested a gift. She remembered that a couple months before they had found this vintage 1970s-era McDonald's uniform in his exact size. And he'd had all these stories of working at McDonald's in high school. So Louise bought this thing for him, to give as a present on Halloween, but never gave it to him.
当Elna的朋友Louise后悔和男朋友Gabe分手，决定想找回Gabe时，Elna建议送个礼物。她记得几个月前他们发现过这件完全是他尺寸的1970年代复古麦当劳制服。他高中在麦当劳工作时有很多故事。所以Louise买了这件东西给他，作为万圣节礼物，但从没送给他。
So he got it from the closet, and I was like, what you have to do is go over to his apartment and leave it at his door. He'll get it. He'll know that you get him, and you love him.
所以她从衣柜里拿出来，我就说，你要做的是去他的公寓，把它留在他的门口。他会得到的。他会知道你了解他，你爱他。
Now, when you suggested this to her, what was her attitude about it?
现在，当你向她建议这个时，她是什么态度？
That's a terrible idea. She was very, very resistant. But then this thing happens when you're with me, apparently, where I just got her all spun up into the idea.
那是个糟糕的主意。她非常、非常抵触。但当你和我在一起时会发生这种事，显然，我只是让她陷入了这个想法。
Your air of confidence drew her in.
你自信的空气吸引了她。
Totally. It's like I put her in a box and shook the box, and then-- or when a kid is going to play pinata, and you turn them around and then push them in the direction--
完全是。就像我把她放进盒子里，摇了摇盒子，然后——或者当一个孩子要玩皮纳塔，你把他们转过去，然后推向那个方向——
Of the pinata. That's what you did to her.
朝着皮纳塔。你对她做了这个。
That's what I did to her, where she eventually just started getting excited about the gesture itself.
我就是对她做了这个，她最终开始对姿态本身感到兴奋。
Which is key. It became about the bold thing that they were doing, versus how Gabe would feel. And it worked out about as well as you would expect. Louise left the box with the gift for Gabe, with no note-- just left it in his building.
这是关键。它变成了他们正在做的那个大胆的事情，而不是Gabe会有什么感觉。结果和你想的一样。Louise留下了那个礼物，没有便条——只是留在了他的楼里。
And so they met up and had this huge blow out fight, where she was like, how come you didn't thank me for the gift? And he was just like, you totally broke my heart. You crushed me. And it actually is offensive that you think that this gift could just instantly make up for all of that.
所以他们见面了，爆发了一场巨大的争吵，她说，你怎么不为这个礼物感谢我？而他只是说，你完全伤了我的心。你碾碎了我。你认为这个礼物能立刻弥补这一切，这其实很冒犯。
Were you surprised?
你惊讶吗？
Shocked. I was waiting like a puppy at the door for her to come in and tell me, thank me.
震惊。我像门前的小狗一样等着她进来告诉我，感谢我。
Yeah.
是的。
And she walked in, and she was crying, and totally devastated, heartbroken.
她走进来，她在哭，完全崩溃了，心碎了。
Elna didn't just organize these kinds of schemes for other people. She did them herself. Like, one time, she was taking tickets as a page for The Letterman Show and met this random guy.
Elna不仅为别人组织这些计划。她自己也做。比如，有一次，她在大卫·莱特曼秀做接待员，遇到了一个随机的家伙。
He was in line to see the show, and we talked very briefly. And I thought I heard a voice that said, "This is who you are meant to be with."
他排队看节目，我们进行了很简短的交谈。我想我听到一个声音说，“这就是你命中注定要在一起的人。”
She knew, of course, from her parents to trust that voice. So she gave this guy her number and dated him for a month and a half, and it went nowhere. Then, two years later, still hung up on this guy, who'd moved to Zambia, she wrote him an email.
她当然知道，从她父母那里，要信任那个声音。所以她给了这个家伙她的号码，和他约会了一个半月，一无所获。然后，两年后，依然挂念着这个搬到赞比亚的家伙，她发了一封邮件。
Which I have here. Do you want me to read the email I wrote?
我这里有。你想让我读我写的邮件吗？
Totally.
当然。
All right. "I don't know if you're still in Zambia, but my girlfriends and I are going to South Africa in the spring to visit some family friends of mine. I'm not sure how far Zambia is from South Africa, but if it's close, I'd love to come up and say hi. It'd be fun to see you. It's been a while. I hope you're well. X, Elna."
好的。“我不知道你是否还在赞比亚，但我女朋友们和我春天要去南非看我的家庭朋友。我不确定赞比亚离南非有多远，但如果很近，我很乐意上去打声招呼。能见到你会很有趣。有一段时间了。希望你一切都好。X，Elna。”
But OK, I did not have a trip to Africa planned.
但好吧，我没有去非洲的旅行计划。
Do you have some sort of friends in South Africa?
你在南非有某种朋友吗？
No, made that up entirely.
没有，完全编出来的。
And then "I don't know if Zambia is near South Africa." Did you actually look on a map?
然后“我不知道赞比亚是否在南非附近”。你真的看过地图吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, OK.
是的，好吧。
But that's why I chose South Africa.
但这就是我选择南非的原因。
She roped two girlfriends into this trip, spent all her money, thousands of dollars on plane tickets. They stayed at this guy's little studio apartment, and on the very first night of a 10 day visit, she snuck over to his sleeping bag, woke him up, and tried to kiss him.
她把两个女朋友拉进这次旅行，花光了她所有的钱，几千美元在飞机票上。他们住在那个家伙的小单间公寓里，在10天访问的第一天晚上，她溜进他的睡袋，把他叫醒，试图吻他。
And he said, I think this is a bad idea.
他说，我认为这是个坏主意。
And so what were the next nine days like?
所以接下来的九天是什么样的？
Really uncomfortable. Yeah.
真的很不舒服。是的。
And then there was the time that Elna tried to drag her friend Heather into pursuing a guy with one of these capers. Heather was one of the friends that Elna took on that trip to Africa. She was a page at The Letterman Show. And Elna would sometimes ask her--
然后还有一次Elna试图拉她的朋友Heather去追一个家伙。Heather是Elna带去非洲旅行的朋友之一。她是莱特曼秀的接待员。Elna有时会问她——
Who do you like? Or tell me about your relationships. And she was always really vague about it. And she would just say that she'd been in love before, but it just hadn't worked out.
你喜欢谁？或者告诉我你的感情状况。她总是对此非常模糊。她只会说她以前爱过，但没成功。
And so I kept fishing for details. Eventually, after a few months, I got out that they were college sweethearts. They'd been together about five years. And it just hadn't worked out.
所以我不断挖掘细节。最终，几个月后，我知道他们是大学恋人。他们在一起大约五年。只是没成功。
And so I kept trying to strategize. I was like, OK, well, we gotta-- if you still love him, we're going to make this work out. What can we do to show him how you feel?
所以我不断尝试制定策略。我说，好吧，我们得——如果你还爱他，我们要让这成功。我们能做什么来向他展示你的感受？
What did you suggest that she might do?
你建议她可能会做什么？
Well, I asked well, when are you planning a trip home? Can you see him? No, I can't see him. Well, why not?
好吧，我问了，你计划什么时候回家？你能见他吗？不，我见不到他。好吧，为什么不？
And then after, maybe six, seven months of this, one day she said, "Look, I feel really bad for not having told you this, but the reason it didn't work out is that he died in a forest fire." And yeah, and they were planning on getting married. He was her whole life, her whole future. She imagined having kids with him.
然后在大约六、七个月后，有一天她说，“看，我因为没告诉你这个感到很抱歉，但没成功的原因是他死于森林火灾。”是的，他们计划结婚。他是她的全部生活，她的全部未来。她想象过和他生孩子。
Although I will say in retrospect, I was like a goldfish. I blinked my eyes, and I was like, well? Like, I took the information, and I was like, well, have you liked anyone since?
虽然我得说回顾过去，我就像一条金鱼。我眨了眨眼，我想，好吧？就像，我接受了信息，我想，好吧，之后你喜欢过谁吗？
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Very sensitive.
非常敏感。
Yeah, I asked her if, in the time since-- which I think had been about two years.
是的，我问她在那之后——我想大约已经两年了。
And the answer was yes, one guy. It was before she moved to New York. She was working at a little puddle jumper airport in Idaho, and was checking in this guy for a flight. And they started talking, had this really nice talk for 45 minutes.
答案是肯定的，一个人。是在她搬到纽约之前。她在爱达荷州的一个小机场工作，正为一个家伙办理航班登记。他们开始交谈，进行了非常愉快的45分钟谈话。
When he was on the airplane, she looked up the roster, found his name, and found that in a week, he was going be flying back through the same airport. So she changed her schedule, made sure she was working at that time, got all dressed up, waited a whole day. He didn't fly through. That was it.
当他在飞机上时，她查了名单，找到了他的名字，发现一周后他会飞回同一个机场。所以她改了时间表，确保她在那个时间工作，打扮得漂漂亮亮的，等了一整天。他没飞过来。就是这样。
And so she finishes the story, and I was like, this is the worst story I've ever heard. That was it?
然后她讲完故事，我想，这是我听过的最糟糕的故事。就是这样？
This is the most tragic. Right, because it seemed like true love to you?
这是最悲剧的。对吧，因为它在你看来像是真爱？
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
Because, just to review, you hadn't been in love yourself yet?
因为，回顾一下，你自己还没谈过恋爱？
Yeah, but I'd been in love at a glance.
是的，但我经历过一眼瞬间的爱。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
That's as far as you had gone.
那是你走到的最远的地方。
Yeah, and it feels-- ah.
是的，而且感觉——啊。
And then Heather admitted she'd googled the guy, found that he worked at a river guiding company. He was in a picture on their website. And every now and then, she would look at the picture. And Elna, of course, was like, great. You know his name. You know where he works. Time to act. Heather responded in the way I think most rational people would.
然后Heather承认她搜了那个家伙，发现他在一家河流向导公司工作。他在他们网站的一张照片里。不时地，她会看那张照片。而Elna当然说，太棒了。你知道他的名字。你知道他在哪工作。是时候行动了。Heather的反应我认为大多数理性人都会那样。
She was like, this dude does not remember me. Like, I'm sure this dude doesn't remember me. It had been like a year and a half since they'd spoken once for 45 minutes. And I was like, well, you never know unless you try. And so I kept at her for, I think, like four months or so, I just kept being like, just write the letter, write the letter.
她就像，这个家伙不记得我了。我是说，我肯定这个家伙不记得我了。距离他们上次谈话已经过去一年半了。而我就像，嗯，不试一下怎么知道。所以我坚持了她四个月左右，我一直就像，写那封信，写那封信。
Then one day, Heather was visiting Elna's apartment, and Elna pulled out a box of fancy stationery.
然后有一天，Heather在访问Elna的公寓，Elna拿出一盒高档信纸。
And I was like, OK, I know we're not going to send this letter, but if we did send it, what would we say? And so I gave her--
我就说，好吧，我知道我们不会寄这封信，但如果我们真的寄了，我们会说什么？所以我给了她——
So sly.
太狡猾了。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
And did she see through your clever stratagem?
她看穿了你的聪明策略吗？
Well, she played along.
好吧，她配合了。
Then Heather was like, how do you get over the problem that I'm writing a letter to this guy a year and a half after we met each other totally out of the blue? Well, here's the letter Elna wrote.
然后Heather就问，既然我们认识一年半了，突然写这封信怎么解决这个问题？好吧，这是Elna写的信。
"Hey, um, you probably don't remember me. We met at the airport. And I made a misstep, missed the opportunity to connect with you then, and it just so happened a year and a half later my younger brother is thinking of being a river guide. And we were looking on sites of river guides, and I came across this picture. And I was like, wait, how do I know that guy?
“嘿，呃，你可能不记得我了。我们在机场见过面。我犯了个错，错过了那次联系的机会，正好一年半后我弟弟想成为一名河流向导。我们在看河流向导的网站，我看到了这张照片。我当时就像，等等，我怎么认识那个人？
Well, I saw him at an airport a year and a half ago. And I thought, wow. I missed that chance then. Let me write him a letter now. So I just wanted to say hello, and you know, here's my email if you ever want to connect."
好吧，我一年半前在机场看到他。我想，哇。我当时错过了那个机会。让我现在给他写封信。所以我只是想打个招呼，你知道，如果你想联系，这是我的邮箱。”
The part that was a lie was her brother wasn't interested in being a river guide.
撒谎的部分是她弟弟对当河流向导没兴趣。
Also, of course, the whole rest of it, stumbling across this picture accidentally, the whole thing. Over the next few months, they drafted and redrafted this letter. And it was like a game. They would show it to people. They would get edits and suggestions.
当然，剩下所有的东西，偶然发现这张照片，整个事情。在接下来的几个月里，他们起草并重新起草了这封信。这就像一场游戏。他们给别人看。他们得到编辑和建议。
Then one day, Heather calls Elna and tells her she sent the letter. And really, for the first time, Elna realized, oh wait, maybe this is a bad idea.
然后有一天，Heather打电话给Elna，告诉她她寄出了那封信。真的，第一次，Elna意识到，噢等等，也许这是一个坏主意。
I don't know. It hit me in that moment that sending the letter would mean that Heather was going to get hurt. And I felt really nervous.
我不知道。那一刻我意识到，寄出这封信意味着Heather会受伤。我感到非常紧张。
Yeah. Because every other time you've tried this, it's failed.
是的。因为你每次尝试这个，都失败了。
Exactly.
确实。
And suddenly you realize, oh, she's going to be hurt, and she was feeling OK, and now I got her hopes up.
突然你意识到，噢，她会受伤，而且她本来感觉还可以，现在我给了她希望。
Yep.
没错。
And she's going to feel bad, and it's my fault.
而且她会感觉很糟，是我的错。
Exactly. Yeah, but then at the same time, I also felt proud of her. Because this was the first-- I felt like she put her heart out again. I guess the consolation in that moment was, this probably isn't going to work out, but she showed the universe, or whatever, that she's willing to try again.
没错。是的，但同时，我也为她感到骄傲。因为这是第一次——我觉得她再次把心放了出来。我想那一刻的安慰是，这可能不会成功，但她向宇宙，或者其他什么，展示了她愿意再次尝试。
Well, she showed herself that she's willing to try again after all the sadness that she'd had with her boyfriend. So does she end up getting a boyfriend after that?
好吧，她向自己展示了她愿意在经历了所有悲伤后再次尝试。所以她之后交到了男朋友吗？
Well, so two weeks later the guy who got the letter wrote back.
好吧，两周后那个收到信的家伙回信了。
Mhm.
嗯。
And it was actually pretty short and friendly. He remembered meeting her, and she left an impression on him too. And they started dating. And they dated for seven years, and now they're married.
实际上很简短友好。他记得见过她，她也给他留下了印象。他们开始约会。他们约会了七年，现在他们结婚了。
What?
什么？
Mhm.
嗯。
Wait, that's the end of the story?
等等，这就是故事的结尾？
Yeah, they actually got together.
是的，他们真的在一起了。
What?
什么？
I know. I gave a toast at their wedding, where I told this story of writing the letter. It's kind of the most magical thing that I've ever helped facilitate.
我知道。我在他们的婚礼上敬酒，我讲了这个写信的故事。这是我曾经促进过的最神奇的事情。
OK, so that worked with her. Do you think these kinds of things are a good idea?
好吧，那对她有效。你认为这些事情是个好主意吗？
Grand gestures?
盛大姿态？
Yeah.
是的。
No, not anymore. And actually, I think it worked--
不，不再是了。实际上，我认为它起作用——
Wait, wait, I'm confused now. Why are they a bad idea?
等等，等等，我现在糊涂了。为什么它们是个坏主意？
It seems false. It's not really how you show someone you love them in the way I thought it was. I feel like it has more to do with you than the other person.
它看起来是假的。这不是你展示你爱某人的方式，我以前认为它是。我觉得它更多是关于你，而不是另一个人。
She actually hasn't done this stuff now in almost a decade, doesn't miss it. And when she looks back on it, she thinks she was doing those big gestures because she was so unsure of herself.
她实际上在过去近十年里没做过这些事了，并不怀念它。当她回顾过去时，她认为她做那些大姿态是因为她对自己太不确定了。
I was afraid that they wouldn't like me, if I just was like, hey, I'm interested in you. This is who I am. I thought maybe you like construction paper, and giant signs, and hot glue gun art.
我担心如果我只是说，嘿，我对你感兴趣。这就是我。我担心如果我那样他们就不会喜欢我。我以为也许你喜欢手工纸、巨大的标语和热胶枪艺术。
Uh-huh.
呃，是的。
And if I'd show you all of that and I'm standing behind it, then if I'm not enough, at least you'll like that, and you'll say yes.
如果我展示了所有这些，而且我站在它们背后，那么如果我不够好，至少你会喜欢那个，你会说愿意。
It's scary being real with another person. And there are so many ways to avoid it. This is just a particularly splashy one.
对另一个人真实是很可怕的。有很多方法可以避免它。这只是一个特别引人注目的方法。
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek. Other staff, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graf.
我们的节目今天由Miki Meek制作。其他工作人员，Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, 和 Diane Wu。今天的研究协助来自Christopher Swetala和Michelle Harris。音乐协助来自Damien Graf。
Students Ivan Webber, Ezri Staheli, and Max Bennion helped with reporting at Payson High School. Thanks to them. Special thanks today to Jesse Sorenson, Clint Peery, Kurt Braunohler, Lauren Cook, Robin Moore, Enrique Lamadrid, Key West Ghost & Mysteries Tour, Clinton Curry at Ghosts & Gravestones, the Diaz-Ayala Collection at Florida International University, and Heather Wright.
学生Ivan Webber, Ezri Staheli, 和 Max Bennion协助了佩森高中的报道。感谢他们。特别感谢Jesse Sorenson, Clint Peery, Kurt Braunohler, Lauren Cook, Robin Moore, Enrique Lamadrid, 基韦斯特鬼魂与神秘之旅, 鬼魂与墓碑的Clinton Curry, 佛罗里达国际大学的Diaz-Ayala收藏, 以及Heather Wright。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has been wiretapping former National Security Adviser Mike Flynn's telephone for months now, and finally today is releasing the audio to the public. We have a clip.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心传递给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torey Malatia先生，他几个月来一直监听前国家安全顾问Mike Flynn的电话，终于在今天向公众发布了音频。我们有一个片段。
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
[胡言乱语]
Just shout random words.
只管喊随机的词。
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
[胡言乱语]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。